so thinking about
uh trauma and stuff that you go through
in your past
um
throughout most of school for me I was
pretty isolated only child uh pretty
unpopular in school and the main issue
that I had was
it wasn't bullying it was isolation I
think it was being lonely right um and
that was
primarily what was causing me to be sad
throughout school so I did this
interview for the BBC about
six months ago and uh in it I talk about
I haven't opened up that much about
bullying I need to do it more and it is
you know even from watching you go
through opening up about your traumas is
inspiring uh so I do this interview for
the BBC and I mentioned a little bit
about bullying in school and
so why don't you mention it
I haven't got around to it yet I I maybe
still feel like it
detracts from the man that I want to be
the masculine man the
respected podcaster that it's somehow
undermines me as a person that it makes
me weaker which is obviously what was
you know part of the bullying's purpose
in school to be able to do precisely
that right so I do this interview for
the BBC and I mentioned in two
paragraphs or something but millions of
people see this article uh and I get
back one day and in my Instagram message
requests is this message from a guy and
I kind of recognize his name but not not
fully and I don't know whether you know
but there's like a character limit in
Instagram so and this is five character
limit messages long with multiple
paragraphs within each of them right so
I open it up uh and this guy says uh hi
Chris you might not remember me but we
went to school together uh I bullied you
my daughter is four and she's about to
go to school and given that she's about
to go to school me and my wife have been
discussing about the kind of child that
we want her to be and that caused me to
reflect on my time that I spent in
school
I saw I've been thinking about messaging
you for a while I've been considering
talking to you because I really felt
like I needed to because I felt ashamed
of the way that I treated you in school
and I knew that it had hurt you
uh and then I saw this article from the
BBC and I just had to reach out and
I've been sleepless nights speaking to
the wife tears and all the rest of it uh
and that's why I just said I'm sorry I'm
very sorry for what I did
um I wanted to let you know that my
daughter
is going to be raised in a way that will
never treat anybody like that again
um I don't expect you to forgive me I
don't even know if you'll see this
message I'm happy to see that you seem
to be happy
um
but I needed to get it off my chest
right
I'm like I've totally taken about it
like wasn't prepared for this I know
I've come back in from the gym or
something and I'm sat reading this
message like hell that's heavy so
I go back through and I think well how
do I feel about this how do I feel about
this person how do I feel about my
experience right
um because it was so formative right
shaped so much of the way that I see
myself the way that I see the world I
had to
deprogram
so much of the patterns that I'd learned
right through that time
um my desire for validation from other
people right my need to be liked my
constant vigilance my ambient anxiety
that was always looking for what was
going on my concern of being laughed out
yep my adamant nature that everybody was
um able to judge something about me that
I didn't know about myself yeah
but this guy you'd like
fully fully opened up to me and I
thought well you know
it was beautiful it was a beautiful
message
um so I replied to him and I said hey
man um
I'd very much appreciate you reaching
out I think it's an incredibly Brave
thing to do
and
if
me going through what I went through and
then the pain and discomfort and such
and your subsequent suffering of
reflecting on what you did
if that has led to a world in which your
daughter
will be the sort of person who will
behave in a manner that's going to make
the world a better place going forward
I think that's a price that's worth
paying that's awesome man
that's that's a great story
that's a great story and
you're the you're the expert on it
that's why you should talk about
bullying I know yeah you're the expert
and that's why I do it
you know um that's why I become I've
I've become so vulnerable
because all that knowledge you gain
because now you are successful
and there's so many people who are
getting bullied in so many ways
that you know
you just show them that there's a path
but the path is really like I talk about
studying the bully
that's the path
studying the bully we have attempted to
become a bully never
never I'm always like I said like I told
you before this started I wanted to be a
priest
I want to be a priest you know and uh
could you imagine one of those sermons
oh it'd be sick because I would cuss
because I would I would definitely cuss
praise the Lord mother that's it I would
definitely cuss I would definitely cuss
man because that's that's the world
and there's a lot of people if I hear
this like oh my God that's this is oh my
God let me close my hair
you know this
the world's tough
and
when you come up the way I came up the
only way I can describe something
sometimes is safe for mother
because that's how dark this was
and I can't make it flowery I can't make
it PG like oh I want my kids to like I
have a clean edition of this book
oh you have a non-explicit version yes
because people like I want my I want my
kid to read your book but you but you
cuss so much I can't I mentioned it's
about half the size yes it's very small
yes so so the funny thing about it is
like how long are you going to
shelter your child
from a world that's evilish
that's going to come at you
it's going to come at you whether you've
been bullied or not there's gonna come a
time
where it's going to come at you
and it's gonna be a lot worse than your
mother
it's gonna be a lot worse
and so we are training kids and people
to be soft in a world that continuously
gets harder
and it doesn't it doesn't correlate like
that guy talking about the tear gas with
the seals is that necessary
I don't know
but what is necessary is you have to
build a person that can withstand the
pressures of whatever they're going to
be dealing with in life
and we don't do that I'm not trying to
send a message of run 200 miles be the
best in the world
but be tough
you better have a part about you that's
tough a part about you that can break
down situations and get better
and break down situations very quickly
Within
some trauma in your life some
Devastation in your life because it's
going to come the devastation the trauma
is going to come and you can't allow
that to become a jersey barrier
it can't be a jersey bear it has to be
something that you can maneuver through
very quickly and move forward that takes
a lot of toughness well
unchosen suffering is going to happen
right so the only thing that you can do
is have some chosen suffering to prepare
for it it's the only thing you can do
that's the only thing you can practice
for the unchosen suffering is have
chosen suffering
do something that sucks every day
this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't I've replaced
my morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
slash modern wisdom thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Goggins then press here for the
full episode in all of its glory and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]